Mir geht es gut, also machen wir uns bereit, ja, hi
Emily, hi, danke, dass du an der Show
teilgenommen hast. Ich habe mehrmals gefragt, aber es ist sehr
interessant für mich. Weißt du, ist dies
die erste Online-Talkshow, an der du teilnimmst
?
Ich denke, es ist mein erstes Ja, und
wenn nicht, würde ich lügen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass
dies mein erstes Ja sein sollte, sehr
cool, wie alles zusammen ist, wir werden sehen,
also, wie läuft es,
alles ist großartig, hier bin ich
Deutschland das ist mein ich denke vielleicht drittes
drittes mal in deutschland es ist wirklich gut ich
sehe nie zu viel von münchen oder
köln oder ich weiß nicht ich wünschte ich hätte
mehr zeit ja es ist so voll damit es
ist immer sehr voll und  und ich wünschte, ich
könnte wirklich erkunden,
woher kommst du aus Köln Ich bin schon mal gegangen, okay, also
bin ich zu weit zum Kölner Turm gelaufen,
beschissen, ich bin gelaufen, ja, ja
, ich dachte, ich würde sterben, nein, aber ich bin
definitiv gelaufen  Die
gesamte sehr kleine Treppe hinauf
dreht es sich, ja, das ist ein O  Bei den berühmtesten
Gebäuden in Deutschland haben Sie ihren
Punkt verstanden. Okay, einige Leute würden sagen, das
stimmt nicht, sie sind berühmter. Nun,
es gibt ein Denkmal für Michael Jackson
vor meinem Hotel, das scheint, als
wäre es ziemlich berühmt. Wow, wir sind vor
dem Hotel  ich weiß nicht okay ich weiß nicht
ich weiß nicht das scheint ziemlich berühmt zu sein
das ist sehr deutsch ja manchmal
so wir haben etwas mehr Zeit oh ja
absolut ja weil es so ein
Wirbelsturm ist in dem ich in vier verschiedenen
Ländern war  die letzten drei wochen ich wünschte
ich hätte mehr zeit ja und du bist in diesem
geschäft seit du acht bist
aber ja ich habe gut angefangen was musik angeht
ich habe angefangen mit musik zu experimentieren als
ich ungefähr 8 war definitiv
in der grundschule angefangen  In der Schule habe ich nur Musikunterricht genommen
und und und du weißt, ich war in Ich
war im Chor und ich war im Chor und in der
Grundschule und in der High School und
halt Damon war Adrians Ich habe gelesen oder ist es
ein bisschen jünger, nein, ich glaube, es war
sechs oder  sieben begannen handeln  ja und du
magst es, du magst es immer noch, nein, auf
jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall, ich habe definitiv Lust darauf.
Weißt du, beides sind unsere großen
Leidenschaften für mich und ich
Ich war
schon immer ein großer Fan von allem, was
musikalisch ist, und ich habe eine große Affinität
zu vielen verschiedenen Bands, also was sagen deine
Freunde dazu, denn sehen sie
dich oft genug, nein, sie sehen mich nie
genug, nein, ich  Das heißt, ich bin nicht so oft zu Hause, wie
ich gerne wäre, aber wenn ich es bin, ist es
irgendwie nett, denn wenn ich zu Hause bin, kann ich
mich irgendwie einfach hinsetzen und einfach
meine ganze Zeit mit ihnen verbringen und dann
es  wird es mehr geschätzt, wenn ich nicht die ganze Zeit da bin,
wie oh, du bist
nur für drei Tage zu Hause, wir müssen kommen, um dich zu sehen
, ja, aber wie ich reise ich jetzt und
ich habe überall Freunde
Welt, also ist es sehr cool, ja, also brauchst du
Facebook Facebook, es ist für dich gemacht,
es ist definitiv für mich gemacht, sicher, ja,
nein, es ist großartig, ich liebe es, ich nehme  it Ich
fotografiere viel, also stelle ich alle meine
Bilder auf Facebook und ja, meine
Freunde können so tun, als wären sie
dort gewesen, okay, also bist du sicher, dass das Leben ein bisschen
wie das von Lily in Hannah
Montana ist, ich meine definitiv in  In gewisser Weise
meine ich ihre Beziehung zu
Miley auf dem Bildschirm ist
vielen Beziehungen sehr ähnlich, in denen ich mein
eigenes Privatleben habe, meine beste Freundin, und ich bin
sehr ähnlich.
Es hat mich immer erstaunt, und wie
oft ich in der Serie, in der
ich wie ihr Vater eins zu eins Zeit mit
Billy Ray
verbrachte, so viel Zeit damit verbrachte, allein zu sitzen und
mit Robby Ray im
Stuart zu essen  Familienküche, es ist so, als wäre es
für sie einfach normal, und ich habe das Gefühl, dass
viele meiner Freunde so sind, wir stehen uns
sehr, sehr nahe
das Gefühl, dass dies
definitiv eines der Missverständnisse ist
Manchmal ist es im Geschäft so,
dass es möglich ist, überall auszugehen,
und für mich lebe ich immer noch an dem Ort
, an dem ich aufgewachsen bin, und ich lebe in Los
Angeles, und ich habe jede Menge Freunde,
entweder aus der Vorschule oder dem Fußball oder dem
Camp oder der Schule  und Sie wissen, dass es so viele, so
viele verschiedene Lebensbereiche gibt, aber in der
Musik und auch in der Schauspielerei, also ist es
für mich einfach, diesen normalen
Lebensstil mit normalen Freunden zu führen, und nicht
nur in Ihrer Nachbarschaft, nein, ich meine,
definitiv, ich kann ziemlich viel
irgendwohin gehen Ich meine ich gehe nicht Ich gehe nicht
mit der Brille in der Mütze und dem Schal aus,
weil ich dann das Gefühl habe, dass das
mehr Aufmerksamkeit erregen wird, aber es gibt bestimmte
Orte, die ich sehen sollte, Disneyland ist irgendwie
rau, ja okay, und ich kann nett sein  von
einem Alptraum, außer dass ich fühle, dass
sie einfach sind, es ist okay, es ist ziemlich
normal, es ist okay, und du brauchst nichts, um
nicht, dass die Leute dich nicht sehen
alle weg von euch  Ah, wir reden, wir reden
so und ich dachte, ich kann nicht bei
dir sein, aber weil sie nicht so redet
, normales Leben, oh, okay, okay,
und du bist jetzt in Europa, warum
willst du die Liste sehen?  das ist meine Haut, uh,
ich war in Europa, ja,
nachdem ich Brasilien verlassen hatte, war ich ein
Agent einiger Shows und Reservisten für mich,
oh, und einige folgen unglaublich, und ich
flog nach London,
und ich machte Werbung und einige  TV-
Shows und einige Auftritte und dann
Spanien für die EMAs vor zwei Nächten, ja,
und jetzt Deutschland, also habe ich überall nur
daran gearbeitet, das
Wort über das Album zu verbreiten, das
gerade herausgekommen ist, und sehr lustig, einen Wirbelwind zu drehen,
ist Europa wichtig  Der Markt für Musik geht
ja, definitiv ja, ich meine, und
besonders meine Produzentin meiner Platte,
Nelly Hooper, ist aus London und hat so
ein gutes Gespür für diesen europäischen Musik-Vibe
und wie
es im Moment sehr tanzbar, sehr elektro, sehr dubstep ist, wie
es eine Menge gibt  von wirklich wirklich coolen
Künstlern com  Ich komme aus Europa und bin ein riesiger
Tinie-Tempah-Fan wie viele wirklich
coole europäische Bands wie Eliza Doolittle,
und ich habe das Gefühl, dass das
wirklich für die Platte beeinflusst wurde, und
natürlich muss ich meine Reittiere hier in
Ordnung bringen, damit deine Platte gut ist  Produziere auf einem Weg
für Europa. Ich
meine, ich habe verstanden, dass das mehr ist. Ich habe
einige meiner Inspirationen bekommen, es war
definitiv definitiv aus Europa, also
viel von Allah. Ich habe sie, eine meiner
Lieblingsbands, die Franzosen  heißen Air
to No Air, ja, ja, es gibt
eine Menge Einflüsse, die einen großen Teil
der Platte beeinflusst haben, okay, und was denkst du
über Europa, wenn du es zum ersten Mal siehst, was
war es, es ist kalt, ja, okay, irgendwie kalt,
es ist schön,
schön  Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es so viel
mehr Geschichte gibt, dass Sie wissen, dass es
greifbar ist. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir
Sie sind. Sie haben Ihre Museen in Ihren
Denkmälern, und Sie können sagen, dass Sie
in Europa sind, und es ist faszinierend und Sie
haben Beweise für die Vergangenheit  Jahrhundert
hier oder ist in  In den Staaten haben wir manchmal
einfach alles abgerissen
und neu angefangen, oder hier habe ich das Gefühl, dass
es eine Menge wirklich cooler, alter, alter
Architektur gibt, und es ist wirklich interessant
, also ist das die Hauptsache für NSE
war mit den Leuten Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass die Leute sehr Ich bin erstaunt,
wie viele Leute
hier drin
so viele verschiedene Sprachen
sprechen
Ihr Englisch ist fantastisch, ich meine,
es ist wirklich verrückt, ich meine, und ich war
eine nette Vertreterin meines
Labels, mit der ich die meiste Zeit zusammen war,
sie spricht vier verschiedene Sprachen,
und ich meine, es ist unglaublich, dass ich kaum eine
spreche und  eine halbe also spreche ich deutsch
und zwei breite sprache und die
weltsprache ist nicht englisch es ist schlechtes englisch
wenn ich mit vielen leuten geredet habe deren
muttersprache nicht englisch ist und
da sagen sie das es viele
verschiedene englisch gibt  kann lernen es gibt da
gibt es klassisches Englisch
es gibt Londoner Englisch und dann gibt es
kanadisches Englisch oder
so und es gibt drei Engländer yeah
oh yeah jetzt habe ich das Gefühl es gibt sie sind
sehr unterschiedlich mit dem Akzent yeah yeah
verstehst du jedes Englisch  Akzent
oder Sie haben auch ziemlich Schwierigkeiten, es
gab einige Male, als
ich in London war, wo
ich nicht zweimal hinsehen und irgendwie noch
einmal darüber nachdenken musste, was sie zu sagen versuchen, und
definitiv ich  Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Irisch
etwas schwer zu verstehen ist Ja, aber nein,
es ist okay, es ist gut, es ist okay, ja, ich
habe gehört, wie fühlst du dich in Europa, wie fühle ich
mich hier
?
in Europa reisen zu können, seit ich ein Kind war, also war
ich in ziemlich vielen Ländern und
es ist nur in Europa selbst und es ist
immer ein Abenteuer,
ja ja, es gibt eine Menge Ich habe das Gefühl,
überall, wo ich hingehe, gibt mir jeder
Schokolade i  Es ist komisch, wie jede Luft
in jedem Hotel, es ist wie hier,
etwas Schokolade, nimm mehr Schokolade,
bitte, ich denke, der europäische Hai war
tatsächlich besser als die amerikanische
Schokolade
schokolade ist die beste schokolade
und du weißt, in köln haben wir ein
schokoladenmuseum vom du hast ein
reisemuseum wir haben einen schokoladenpark
in pennsylvania oh ja oh okay
das hast du nicht weißt du das du
essen
musst wir haben museen  in Europa und hast
du den Preis? Ich bin Amerikaner
ja okay also das wäre sehr
interessant ich werde mich ihnen anschließen wenn ich in
Erinnerung bin hast du die Staaten besucht ja
in New York ich war in New York okay
es ist eine gute Vertretung ja  Ich denke,
ja, New Yorker, ich bin stolz, dass Sie in
Sonora Senor sind, Sie sind einfach Herz und
Seele. ja, okay, das nächste Mal in New York, ja,
okay, vielen Dank, alles
klar, fragen Sie danach, danke